[Applaudissements]
pour la première fois depuis son
élection
volodimeersky s'avance à la tribune de
l'ONU l'an dernier le président
ukrainien avait été contraint de
s'exprimer depuis son pays en guerre
cette fois-ci le dirigeant représente sa
population et notamment les enfants
kidnappés par l'occupant russe
nous essayons de récupérer ses enfants
mais le temps passe que va-t-il se
passer pour ses enfants
que va-t-il leur arriver en Russie on
apprend à ses enfants à haïr l'Ukraine
et tous les liens avec leur famille sont
rompus et c'est clairement un génocide
génocide utilisation de la nourriture
comme d'une arme Zelenski x les
accusations contre Moscou face à
l'invasion russe le président réclame
l'unité mondiale et invite les
dirigeants à un sommet de la paix à Kiev
une initiative appuyée par ses alliés
occidentaux au premier rang desquelles
les États-Unis
nous soutenons fermement l'Ukraine et
ses efforts pour parvenir à une
résolution diplomatique qui garantissent
une paix juste et durable seule la
Russie porte la responsabilité de cette
guerre seule la Russie a le pouvoir de
mettre fin à cette guerre immédiatement
et seule la Russie s'opposent à la paix
un soutien plus nuant séché certains
pays du Sud qui s'abstiennent de livrer
des armes à l'Ukraine ou de sanctionner
la Russie le président Lula continue de
promouvoir une résolution diplomatique
de la guerre
nous ne sous-estimons pas les
difficultés à parvenir à la paix mais
aucune solution ne sera durable si elle
n'est pas fondée sur le dialogue
mercredi volodiniers participent à une
réunion spéciale du Conseil de sécurité
de l'ONU avant de s'envoler pour la
Maison Blanche où il sera reçu par Joe
Biden